la municipalité de vallée jonctions
ancien pôles ferroviaire avec sa gare
stratégiquement située faites cette
année son 125e anniversaire mais avec la
fermeture de l'usine de l'email
personnelle cœur à la fête la
déflagration est telle que c'est toute
la vallée de la chaudière qui en ressent
les contrecoups
demeure dans une municipalité voisine il
travaille depuis 7 ans à l'usine de
l'email on sait frustré pas mal on n'a
pas eu d'avertissement rien on ne sort
dans les médias puis de plusieurs qui
sont en couple en est deux à part d'un
job en même temps autour d'une tasse à
café le couple est encore terriblement
ébranlé monsieur Bellay 64 ans qui
s'était blessé au travail se demande
s'il pourra se trouver un autre emploi
quand on monte en orge comme ça leurs
collègues vivent aussi des heures
d'angoisse
je suis rentré là puis demandez pas
grand chose là fait que j'ai été
chanceuse puis de retrouver un autre job
avec un bon salaire ça peut être sûr
à payer
de 6 ans en plus
c'est pas évident même si le taux de
chômage est au plus bas en bourse la
requalification de plusieurs des 1000
travailleurs risquent d'être longue et
ardues l'usine de l'email fait partie du
quotidien et des gens de Labosse et de
vallée jonctions depuis plusieurs années
tout le monde connaît quelqu'un qui
travaille c'est pourquoi la fermeture
crée un tel choc au sein de la
communauté c'est vraiment manque de
respect polémique a travaillé pendant 45
ans l'abattoir même si on l'e-mail
soutient que l'usine nécessitait des
investissements importants il se
questionne encore sur les raisons de la
fermeture dans les cas usines c'est
celle-là de balai qu'on nous dit qui est
encore la plus rentable que toujours été
la plus rentable
puis décide de la fermer il décide de la
fermer
le froid et le travail à la chaîne
qu'on veut
c'est dur il espère ainsi que l'email
versera une prime au travailleur ce qui
n'est toutefois pas dans les plans de
l'entreprise
mais ça c'est la moins des choses
d'autres communiquent sont venus de
Madagascar pour travailler chez l'email
parce que ça m'aide beaucoup c'est à
cause de lui que je suis devenu ici
c'est à cause de lui que c'est mon
enfance en canadiennes aussi et les
pleurs le milieu des affaires
d'embaucher des travailleurs étrangers
des
usines et des employeurs ici en poste
pour offrir son leur porte pour notre
ami immigrants et pour donner une flotte
emploi pour eux malheureusement je pense
que oui
la fermeture fera mal on s'attendait pas
à ça juste avant que
on s'est dit on est correct on va on va
passer à travers mais là malheureusement
c'est pas le cas pour lui il s'agit de
deuxième coup dur après les inondations
2019 on a fermé 6 mois on a tout rénové
à grandeur on a ouvert les murs on a
isolé les murs tout le tour à 4 pieds mi
des membranes sur le soleil on a des
boréacs qui s'installent dans les portes
si jamais le mot on est on espère
waterproof
[Musique]
patrimoniaux qui faisait partie de
l'histoire de la bosse qui sont disparus
les signes destructeurs des inondations
sont partout dans les municipalités à
plusieurs endroits on peut y voir une
entrée asphaltée et on imagine à
l'arrière une maison qui n'existe plus
seulement avalé jonctions 60 bâtiments
ont été rasés
donc c'est des terrains vides avalé
jonctions on peut pas faire 60 parcs
quand il y a même pas 60 rue plusieurs
résidences à quitté leur demande c'est
le cas de Kevin
kleechon
très jeune ce dernier a finalement
trouvé une maison mais plusieurs
citoyens ont dû quitter la municipalité
faute de pouvoir se loger tout le monde
s'est retrouvé pas de maison pas de
place à la location toutes les prix on
le veulent les inondations 2019 sont
ordinaires il commence à se relever
après autant de difficultés certains
mises sur le passé ferroviaire de la
communauté mais aussi sur le dynamisme
de l'économie Bosseron
ici on rentre dans le musée ferroviaire
de Rennes c'est notamment le cas de
François Clichy qui mis sur le musée
situé dans la gare construite en 1917
qui a longtemps été un moteur économique
d'illustre personnage non fréquenté
notamment l'ancien Premier ministre
Wilfrid Laurier lors d'une campagne
électorale avec les années on a rajouté
du matériel roulant ferroviaire donne
belle locomotive à vapeur de 1914 et on
a bien des projets encore le
municipalité mise aussi sur le transport
de marchandises l'ancien pont
ferroviaire a été rasé un nouveau sera
construit
ferroviaire peut-être que ça va apporter
des entreprises à vouloir s'installer à
proximité de la voie ferrée
entend aussi relancer l'usine de l'email
j'ai également des propositions à faire
à mon conseil municipal à mes
conseillers j'ai plein d'idées en tête
aussi comment survire de bord les
Bossons jamais les bras mais c'est des
gros défis qui sont qui sont devant les
gens devant les jonctions
[Musique]
et un peu comme la chanson de Richard
Anthony les gens là-bas souhaitent
réentendre le train porteur d'activités
économiques de nouveaux défis pour les
gens et noirs jamais à court d'idées
pour affronter le pire